Let's say there are two types of people for simplicity—type A and type B.
Type A are the popular ones.
They have 80 friends.
And type B are less popular. They only have 20 friends.
You might now say that I don't know which type you are.
I will compute what's called the expected or average number of friends.
To do so, I assume that half of the people are of type A
and half of the people are of type B.
Here's your very first quiz in this class.
Into this box enter what you think is the expected or average number of friends
if you have a 50% chance of being a type A and a 50% chance of being a type B.
Type in here when you're done.
There is a submit button somewhere down here.
You can see if your answer is correct.
Regardless of whether you finish this or not,
at some point just hit the next button,
and you'll see my answer.